[Musique]
c'est ici que les plus grands noms de
l'histoire de france venait se reposer
au coeur de la forêt de rambouillet de
françois 1er à louis saez et marie
antoinette ou encore le général de
gaulle cette résidence a traversé les
siècles depuis le moyen âge des années
qui commençait à peser sur l'édifice
oh
on avait des fuites et puis certaines
parties d'enduit
s'enlevait l'isolation des salles a été
très mauvaise parce que les menuiseries
daté du xviiie siècle pour la plupart
donc on a entamé cette campagne de
restauration en 2015 on restaurant
entièrement le clos et le couvert
c'est à dire de la charpente en
comprenant la toiture les menuiseries et
les façades
tout a été entièrement restauré pendant
deux ans qui ont donc un éviter la
fermeture du château pendant cette
période coût du chantier plus 2,5
millions d'euros
des travaux qui touchent à leur fin
quelques installations à l'intérieur
préparent la réouverture du 15 septembre
le public pourra re découvrir la grande
variété des pièces du château comme ses
boiseries rocaille du xviiie siècles
considérés comme les mieux conservés en
france aujourd'hui où les chiffres de la
comtesse de toulouse un coup on est chez
napoléon un coup on est chez le comte de
toulouse
un coup on est dans l'appartement des
chefs d'état étrangers
tu as des appartements d'époques
différentes qui se succèdent
justement donc ça invite vraiment le
visiteur à faire un voyage à travers le
temps
un voyage avec une exposition du 15
septembre au 22 janvier sur la famille
bourbon toulouse penthièvre propriétaire
du château au xviiie siècle pour les
journées du patrimoine de nombreuses
animations seront proposées aux
visiteurs